shortly after joe biden won and it
looked like control of the u.s senate
was going to come down to
two seats in georgia we knew that the
best case scenario was
50 50 with democrats technically having
a majority
because kamala harris gets to cast the
tie-breaking
51st vote if all 50 democrats are on the
same page
about a particular issue or bill or
whatever the case may be and so
when we knew that that was going to be
the scenario i started talking about joe
manchin
and as the most conservative democratic
senator in the u.s senate i said back in
november december joe manchin could be a
formidable impediment to joe biden
getting things done that he claims that
he wants to do
and my audience was split some in my
audience
understood the magnitude of it they
understood why i was talking about joe
manchin
some denied it and said nah joe
manchin's not going to really be that
big of an obstacle
as we are clearly seeing now with joe
manchin
opposed to so much of what joe biden
wants to do
we realize that he is indeed
a formidable obstacle and now on top of
this we're learning something
about why and it's absolutely horrifying
in an interview with cnn over the
weekend
senator joe manchin straight up says the
january 6th
trump riots made him realize
that we need bipartisanship and we need
to placate
the rioters wait what
he correctly says in this clip that i'm
going to play for you
that he was shocked by the direct attack
on the basic institutions of government
and democracy on january 6th as we all
should have been and many of us were but
joe manchin says it made him decide
he needs to seek bipartisanship period
he can't just go along with whatever joe
biden wants to do
the violence and what is essentially
the the terrorism the hostage taking it
worked in exactly the way
that the terrorists wanted he is saying
when terrorists hold me hostage i
negotiate with them
listen to him and then we're going to
talk about it more january 6 changed me
and i was very clear with everybody
i never thought in my life i never read
in history books
to where our form of government had been
attacked
at our seat of government which is
washington dc at our capital
by our own people now the british did it
but not americans
so something told me wait a minute pause
hit the pause button something's wrong
you can't have this many people split to
where they want to go to war with each
other can you imagine
joe manchin now stands in the way of
much of what
joe biden wants to do because he wants
bipartisanship thanks to people who
stormed the capital
and did violence and committed crimes
and wanted the loser
donald trump to be installed as
president right that's what they wanted
completely anti-democratic
completely against the law completely
against everything the country
supposedly stands for
whether joe manchin intends to or not
whether joe manchin realizes it or not
he is encouraging them to do it again
the reaction
to the violent riots should not be you
know that really shocked me
that they were willing to do that so i'm
gonna be
more bipartisan and play to their side
so that we don't have as big of a
disagreement in this country between
right and left that's the wrong reaction
he is playing to those who rioted saying
i will now
vote in the senate in a different way
that will be closer to what those who
rioted want the reaction
should be those who rioted should be
held accountable
there should be consequences rather than
rewards he's talking about rewarding
them
we must not give the impression that
what they did on january 6th
is valid political speech or activism if
you do what they did on january 6th
they should get nothing from joe manchin
or anybody you should be
invalidating voices that use crime
to get their points across and yet joe
manchin is saying
you know the writers made me realize
we're too divided so
you know i'm not gonna go with stuff joe
biden wants if there isn't republican
support
what what he he wants to bridge the gap
between the rioters and the non-rioters
give me a break joe
the primary takeaway from january 6th
is that we have to protect the country
from the
influence of people who are willing to
do what the rioters did
we should be giving them no role in
policy or governance whatsoever
not to cater to them this is backwards
logic from joe it's not even logic quite
frank i don't know why it's it's
there's no logic here it changed him
he says apparently for the worse they
intimidated him
and it worked he should be recommitting
to only consider the ideas of
non-rioters it's a completely bizarre
argument and reaction they were trying
to kill him
and his reaction is let me let me give
them more of what they want
after 9 11 should we have said you know
we maybe we should look at giving al
qaeda some stuff
i don't know i mean they were really
angry and so they did 9 11.
maybe that anger means we should give
them some stuff it's backwards
it's backwards so that's joe manchin
giving us now a framework we've been
wondering you know what is it with joe
manchin
this is we now understand the framework
under which joe manchin is operating in
the senate
i don't know how you work with a guy
like that and
um yeah i know that we often have this
debate we'll just primary joe manchin
and like put bernie sanders in i don't
think bernie sanders
wins in west virginia i think you just
get a republican
it's about we have to look at other
places i mean sure
primary mansion if you want if you
successfully do it might lead to a
republican but at the same time
we have to be looking at states races in
which in 2022
a republican senator can be removed and
a democratic senator can be put in
hopefully one
who is a more reliable uh vote
than uh joe manchin has been let me know
what you think
this strikes me as could not possibly be
more backwards find me on twitter at
deepakman
let me know your thoughts